coronavirus vaccine research
is perhaps the most wanted information
on the planet
but rather than wait for a breakthrough
russian hackers are accused of trying to
steal it
i think that's pretty appalling i have
to say at a time where the world's
coming together uh we're all trying to
find a vaccine that both our people and
people around the world can benefit from
uh to have the russian government
engaged in that endeavor
i think is needs calling out and i think
the world should know it
oxford university and imperial college
london
among a list of suspected targets they
say they're working with gchq's cyber
security hub to protect themselves
there's no reason for us to believe at
this point that anything has been
stolen but we have seen attacks this is
a sophisticated group of attackers so we
need to be watchful
what evidence do you have that make
gives you so much confidence that it it
was them
we have a robust framework for assessing
this and we've assessed
that it's almost certain that this was
the russian intelligence services and
that's a very high degree of confidence
from us
the uk joined with the us and canada to
accuse russia
saying covet 19 vaccine and treatment
research globally
is being targeted in the frame a group
called
apt-29 or cozy bear which the allies say
is almost certainly part of russia's
intelligence services
they're accused of scanning computer
networks to find vulnerabilities
or using spear phishing emails to gain
access to systems
once inside the attackers allegedly use
malware
perfect for spying and stealing data the
national cyber security centre here in
central
london is taking the lead in calling out
russia
it's a deliberately public move designed
to deter
but cyber spying is only one of an array
of deniable tactics
used by states against each other to
meddle in their affairs
the uk also for the first time admitting
russian interference in last december's
election
it involves a leak of documents first
exposed by a british online investigator
this is a big deal for the first time
you do have the government saying
it looks like somebody tried to
interfere directly in one of our main
democratic processes
and they're willing to say it was
russian actors it's a really important
reminder that
election interference wasn't unique to
the us in 2016.
britain accuses russia of other dirty
tricks like the salisbury spy poisoning
moscow denied that allegation and it
dismissing the new claims about vaccines
and elections
relations between the uk and russia
still in the deep freeze
debrahing sky news